thank you
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
another exciting episode of the careful
boys and today we have Mr Jason Cheney
in the building everyone everyone
[ __ ] loves it
you're the most requested guest but you
I want to comfort myself too let's give
it up for face and face Yay give it up
for self-love self-love dude
I love myself I love my
um
body yeah wow is that your favorite
thing about your body you ever been
caught loving yourself yeah yeah I like
to I love my feeling when I touch my
penis that is a great second ever got
boring for you what has it ever got
boring when I jerk off yeah you ever
been like that's a good question yeah
that's a very good question
um you know what I was always afraid to
be
boring like jerking off to be doing
because I'm like then sex wouldn't be
good so you you're very disciplined you
save it you savor it I never overdo it I
don't I you know what a couple times
okay seven times I thought all guys in
one day in one day that's that's pretty
high no that's Heaven no you have that
what's the highest you guys all got in
one day go I lost count but I I did it
up
I did it to the point where there's
nothing coming out that's about it just
he's like this yeah I think mine was
only like four or five times yeah yeah I
couldn't do nothing just jack off after
the third time you're like baby two or
three two or three wow I don't I don't
think I've tried to pursue like maximum
and each time I feel guilty and guiltier
that's what I'm saying I think after
like three it's like I can't do this you
do feel like a loser
what kind of loser like dude an hour and
a half just went by right now and I did
nothing I was like in eighth or ninth
grade
and when I did that I was like I need to
train for my future girlfriend that's
what I thought too because I was like I
have such a weak dick I come in like 30
seconds yeah that's what I thought and
I'm like there's no way she's gonna
enjoy this [ __ ] so I have to train and I
train for many years and I still came
after 30 seconds but the problem is
because you're training with your hand
and no chick is gonna know your dick
better than your hand true but then
that's what's real yeah feels better
than my hand so even if you train up to
work up to do two minutes you gotta
reset but you got a relationship reset
cause you [ __ ] go in the [ __ ] and
then you come in 20 seconds you do are
you trying to say that only another guy
would be able to do it only my other
hand maybe has the same understanding
that's true it's like uh it's like
[ __ ] Avatar the blue people one it's
like the first guy died and his twin
brother had to take his Avatar that's
the only other situation anyways so
today what we would love to talk about
but that's what I'm saying is that today
what we love to talk about
what are you gonna say I want to hear
what this guy why do you go to bulldoze
bulldoze is a good word is have you ever
been caught loving yourself
I said loving yourself because I'm
trying to be jacking off this is a
serious whoa a serious conversation that
I know many of the viewers they could
totally relate to yeah probably more
dudes than chicks have you ever been
have you ever been caught jacking off
yeah my grandma
that was a major starting with Grandma
my grandma no because I lived with my
grandma and uh she came in oh okay when
I was it doesn't make it any less fun
because then you guys catch each other
sometimes yeah how old were you oh how
old were you
um
Maybe
fifth grade oh she started early sixth
grade
because I remember
I remember the first time it was fifth
grade that I jerked off me too dude to
your hand to your hand yeah like so
someone told you it's a good one too
because I so my friend who got held back
like two years he was my friend
yeah if they're just tuning in right
after that between my purse right
okay so your friend that's your friend
that was my friend and there's another
friend so I have two friends got it and
um
the friend who got held back he's like
man are you guys jerking off you know
and then I was like yeah but I didn't
know what it was what gave them that
suspicion to ask a question like just in
the back of the class and he it just
came up he's like oh you guys jerking
off or whatever like just be like Oh I'm
jerking off or whatever the thing is you
know boys talk about that yeah boy talk
yeah boy talk okay and then so I was
like yeah but I never have jerked off
just to fit in I see you lied about it
because everybody's like yeah it's a lot
of pressure yeah yeah there's a lot of
pressure because I want to be cool too
yeah and then um he was like um
I was like yeah how'd you jack off
because I feel like everybody would do
it such a fifth grade [ __ ] question
yeah how would you do it huh and he said
he put his hand under the pillow and
then uh humped the side of the bed I was
like yeah I do that too but I like it
you know with two pillows or whatever
that I said and then I tried it that
night and that's not a good one you're
like this is stupid this will never work
this way but then that was that's why in
fifth grade that's the first time that I
started that's why I said fifth grade
maybe but you didn't jizz or anything I
did just so so I felt something I go oh
what's this and then I stopped because
I thought like it was supposed to be not
good yeah like broken or something yeah
but you guys
and then I was like no I'm not a quitter
so I wanted to finish it yeah and then
it came out I was like wow Christmas
Christmas would it be Christmas we'll
come because it's a celebration and I
told him it looks like tinsel that's the
highest level when you're a fifth grader
[ __ ] was no we're coming out but it was
just like it was like this it was clear
it was nothing oh you had cleared yeah I
remember thinking the first it's not
even white the first time I was I busted
I was like oh I'm gonna pee so then I
did this oh oh you capped it and then
you know that's that wasn't so it turned
into it and it went inside it went back
down I just let it drain back in yeah I
was like in like fourth or fifth grade
too okay yeah I had an older kid that
told me like hey they teach you it's a
word of mouth thing it is what's that
and then you go home and experiment it's
a total Word of Mouth thing like he told
me you use sunscreen or Vaseline I use
lotion yeah watermelon had a whole box
of kleenexes next to me yeah yeah
classic I used my grandma's uh vibrating
neck pillow thing that she had wow so
she had this neck another Grandma
relationship she had a I [ __ ] nutted
all over that [ __ ]
I didn't know how to jack off like that
my first experience was using a massager
yeah and then so like she had this back
massage not very Japanese and then like
you could put it you've probably seen it
it looks like a scarf thing where you
kind of like yeah yeah you connect it
and then like there's a button and then
the back goes like that right so then
um you know I used to just play with it
on my shoulder and all that and then one
day it found its way on my dick yeah
yeah
that's [ __ ] bomb what the hell is
this
yo this is the bomb right question and I
was like I don't want to hold it like
this let me try this way and then like I
try wrapping around my dick and all kind
and then I was so addicted to using that
thing I [ __ ] smothered it with so
much like pre-cum that [ __ ] was crispy
covered in pre-cooked are you even
imagining women or were you just like
this feels good
that was my first I think it was fifth
grade too that was like I was like this
is good uh Mr Joe I have the million
dollar question did you ever see your
grandmother use it afterwards
yeah but I don't know if they knew that
I was busting out for sure they didn't
know dude it looked like Snot was all
over that [ __ ] yeah but how did you feel
seeing your grandma have your [ __ ]
pre-cum on her neck dude I was
we'll see if I don't remember [ __ ] I
just remember oh that's my that's my toy
right there
yeah vibrating [ __ ] is like um so like I
got this birthday present it was this
big [ __ ] pencil and it vibrates like
this right so it's like those vibrating
toothbrushes and then I was like what if
it's just a toy feels good yeah it's
like a toy and then I [ __ ] grab my
dick and I put put my dick tip on it and
I was like God damn this is [ __ ] sick
and if I just found out all these things
Joe toy reviews dude I was getting into
my uncle's [ __ ] back massager thing
and I was like beating my dick with it
stone is getting horny yeah he's all in
Sharper Image just like put his dick on
everything bro
but I didn't know to grab my dick and
and stroke it you know the manual snitch
I just [ __ ] put it on vibrating
things dude hey you're [ __ ] ahead of
the game of Technology yeah yeah and
then your Blade Runner same same stuff
older kids
jacking off it feels good when you come
and I'm like what are those things and
I'm like oh I used um I use like a
massager and then they were just like
what like they never even thought of
that yeah and then I was like well what
is this jacking off thing you're talking
about and then I just tried it and I'm
like At first I was like man it doesn't
feel as good as a vibrator yeah but then
I'm not a quitter like you you know I
just had to keep trying and trying
unlike you you said you're not a quitter
I'm not I mean I'm like like like you
I'm like you also am not a quitter yeah
I'm not a quitter yeah like you quits I
opened up the the floodgates and then my
friends were much more open about it
like
I had a friend in elementary school this
fool would [ __ ] have his hand like
this or this other hand like this
[ __ ] jacking off while he's doing
homework and [ __ ] in school and I'm
sitting right there you know how the
tables in elementary school used to be
like this where everyone's facing each
other and I'm sitting right there enough
who's doing a fumblethon what yeah and I
remember we were at the auditorium and
this was Jack he would jack off like
this like he's [ __ ] sanding down some
oh [ __ ] you know was he Japanese as well
no he's Mexican his name is Emmanuel so
you'd be like this thanks and then his
buddy would copy him doing this [ __ ]
right and then like and then like the
teacher would be like Emmanuel what are
you doing and he was like oh [ __ ] lo
siento
and then his technique was he would he
would do an okay sign yeah and then he
would get his fingers like this and he
would go
like that dude how the [ __ ] do you know
this technique he showed me all the
techniques that Joe has expressed is
like crazy that's very Advanced I'm
telling you this guy's a sexual Maverick
gonna start with we talked about the uh
the water pressure technique right uh
right we [ __ ] uh the jacuzzi no no
look at the jacuzzi hole not [ __ ]
just like like your bathtub
um oh the yeah and just putting the
pressure on the [ __ ] back your dick
yeah yeah that's that's gross there's
the shower head yeah yeah yeah that's
for girls for girls right Jason we
didn't do that I I did
no but did you do you guys come uh do
you guys come so you guys come easy no
because like from like the vibrators you
know and then from like all this does it
desensitize you you have the sense that
thank you I came fast until like my
mid-30s oh good and then now I think I I
take a longer do you need stuff like oh
you know I need a candle or whatever
yeah dude or like a fan or I need like I
needed like candles it's not romantic
enough yeah I need some rose petals I
need to do a whole kabuki dance and then
jack off because the thing is if because
people talk about the VR
the things I cannot do that why because
if I do it it's too crazy too far I
won't leave the house yeah I'll just
stay there though it's like returning is
it good yeah no I've never done it but I
don't know how good it would be yeah
because the porno is going to be too
real too real porno world and then now I
gotta buy pocket [ __ ] yeah it's the
whole thing it's not that good though no
way it's not that good no you gotta buy
a good one I tried it it's not that good
you talking about flashlights yeah it's
not that good
I think real [ __ ] is the best you just
shattered his dreams right now
but oh you know what though it's so
Advanced since then like there's dark
night and all those other things that I
still haven't tried yet
are you ever gonna do the Dark Knight
Joe you gotta step up and get that I
should I know patreon exclusive The Dark
Knight looks like I'll make you tap out
it like moves for you you just put it on
the wall it looks like it'll remove your
skin it does like a [ __ ] circular
motion like that but then it does a
thousand you remember when the chick was
eating the corn on a power drill and
then her hair got caught and then it
ripped off that's like the darkness yeah
that's not good yeah it'll pull it off
for sure yeah so you're saying your
grandma caught you my grandma what did
she say to discipline you did she like
yell at you she didn't really discipline
me because she will come in and she'll
be like what are you doing and it's like
my dick is in my head what do you mean
you know what the [ __ ] this is why do
you call me you know what though you're
the one getting mad like you know what
the [ __ ] this is why are you coming here
you know what I'm doing yeah it's like
the age where I do you have any material
like uh magazine or a computer or
anything oh um magazine like because I
remember I will go to the the
um newspaper there's like a newspaper
area that people would leave newspaper
and I will find like some ladies a
square and then I'll rip it like
lingerie section or lingerie section or
or like escort advertisements a manga
oh that's nice and then I'll go oh this
is a good rest
and then but they're like anime
characters yeah yeah but I liked it yeah
and I saved up like seven of them and
I'll switch them I'll go yep that's
Jessica
[Laughter]
you named it yeah
who's your favorite those stashes man I
liked among this anime one
um she looked like a nice lady
what did you name her did you name her
anything no I I didn't name her because
I want her to be herself and
um but that's really that's actually
very wholesale I'm actually subscribed
to a a really good series
um like Koreans are getting pretty good
at hentai too like hentai like the the
manga style like the sexy manga yeah
yeah and there's this online like top uh
you can get normal ones too but it's
called two mix and [ __ ] and then there's
the adult ones and the regular ones but
the stories are so good they're really
really good I can't do the stories like
whatever really the stories is it's like
a romance novel for men it's good I jump
it oh really you just go straight to the
show me the titties right he's all
disappointed he'll subscribed to a
Korean hentai service yeah a lot of the
artists are from Korea oh yeah two mix
two mixers I think that's what it's
called
but it's a good uh it's really good but
you really like the story that turns you
on that makes you horny yeah it's too
yeah but they have they have regular
ones too but I think like a lot of
different artists just upload their
Comics here and you can buy the
subscription oh the comics yeah it's all
com it's like it's it's like manga so
they have adult and they have not like
just everybody like just regular stories
too but what's a good story what what's
like a recent story that you read that's
like oh man yeah what's a good premise
it was a synopsis okay this is one where
um this guy's like a streamer right so
he's like he's no one comes to his
streams and [ __ ] and then like he's like
you [ __ ] loser and whatever right and
then one day like
um this girl in him they they flirt on
camera and then they're like yo show us
more and then like and then like little
by little he gets more and more money
and then like they become like this um
[ __ ] couple a camp but he's conflicted
because he's like I wanted to be like a
[ __ ] mukbang guy but I'm selling out
and doing this [ __ ] cam sex [ __ ] but
then at the same time like Ugh it makes
it pays the bills and then for her too
she's like oh like I'm not a [ __ ] but I
gotta pay the bills but like it does so
well and and they have to [ __ ] because
they have to at that part you're like
rock hard dude way before that way
before
way before the backstory the dialogue I
just out of curiosity like how long are
these Comics or is it like they're short
they're like how fast can you read very
well I'm like this I don't know
they're like 10 page episodes yeah or
something like that take me from
yeah but it's like it's like good it's
like it's like the it's like the whole
like oh my God we gotta do it but we
can't do it you know yeah like the real
life [ __ ] yeah like you got to do it for
the money type stuff and you're like oh
my God that's me yeah
oh my God that's me that's real there's
one guy he's like a uh agent for a K-pop
band or like he was an age he was a he
was assistant right and then
um he's all like he's a really good
assistant but like he kind of gets
bullied by the K-pop girls but at the
same time they use them for sex because
they get horny too you know that's my
real [ __ ] he gets bullied by K-pop bully
by the K-pop girls you know he's keep
bringing them coffee and [ __ ] and
they're kind of mean but then at the
same time like they get drunk and then
like he takes care of him he's a good
gentleman you know like kind of a samp
but then like they also like feel like
you know what you're not like other guys
you're like a [ __ ] good guy and then
they suck his dick whoa yeah dude whoa
Justice's story yeah that's Justice yeah
our new tech dude that's justice so good
the stories are really really good it's
very very good I feel like that gives
Empower
um the the Asian guy do I mean that you
know they go oh yeah yeah
Asian empowerment Asian agent
empowerment the best one that's what
gets you off best one is like um this
guy you know
um he I just like to see the [ __ ] juice
he's like he's his parents his parents
are like
his parents are inviting
um his family friends to come over
because their house had a fortunate
accident the whole house got [ __ ]
broken down from an earthquake or
something right and then they come over
and then it's a husband and wife some
kids wife is [ __ ] hot as hell but
abusive abusive husband he's so mean
whatever and then they stay in the same
room he gets a big ass boner she notices
so she plays with this dick to help him
relax yeah and then they become [ __ ]
buddies and then and then it's it's
Forbidden Love because she's married and
she has kids and they shouldn't be
[ __ ] but then she likes his young
dick because he treats her so good and
he's young he's young who's he in the
story I've missed that sorry he's the
son of the of the father of the father
no no no so like his family took in
another family oh okay and then the the
family that they took in has a hot
younger son hot wife a hot wife I think
I think I'm with him I just want to see
the [ __ ] juice how did that sounds too
complicated for me the [ __ ] juice is
amazing Joe's kind of a romantic yeah I
am people say you just watch porn all
day that's all you do you look like that
I like the story
you know what you're a different guy
yeah once you get past the fact that
you're subscribed to Like a Porn service
it's like the fact that you look for the
real story how much does it cost but
it's a written one I think it was like
it's in yen
13 bucks for three months or something I
don't know oh that's a good deal it's a
good deal because I don't be inspired
for life I don't do only fans you know I
just never got myself to do it yeah is
it I never bought a cam girl never did
it I just like to watch the live stream
all these things I don't know why I feel
like nah I can't do that but a story I
will buy yeah porn porn it's
non-exploitative I don't really buy porn
because it's not real people it's art
bro but you're reading this art yeah
it's you know what it is I'm getting
turned on by another man's imagination
the creativity yeah I never saw it that
way I never realized my boy
men no men
laughs
foreign